Now, if I asked you to solve for
x, given, 5(x+10)-30=5x-18,
we would find something
else kind of interesting.
Distributing the 5 to the x and the 10,
we get 5x+50-30=5x -18.
Let's combine like terms and
we get 5x+20=5x-18.
And again,
things are looking a little funny here.
We have a 5x on both sides.
If I were to subtract
5x from both sides,
I would get 0+20=0-18.
20=-18, so of course,
20 does not equal -18,
that means that this equation is false,
and in algebra,
we call this a contradiction.
And again,
the important thing to remember is that,
if you try to solve an equation for
x and
end up with a false statement like this,
the solution is actually no solution.
That means, it doesn't matter
what value you substitute for
x, the equation will
always end up being false.